GRAND JURY AND IT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN NOW.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU BOTH
>> THANK YOU.
YORK LEE ZELD CONTINUE SAYS
HE WANTS THE EVIDENCE RELIED
RIGHT AWAY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: YOU SAY THE
PAGE OUGHT TO BE RELEASED TO
THE PUBLIC.
WHAT'S THE ARGUMENT AGAINST
THAT?
>> ARGUMENT AGAINST IT SOME
INFORMATION FISA APPLICATION
REVIEWING ALL THE DOCUMENTS
THAT ARE L. REVEAL SOURCES
AND METHODS THAT MAY NEED TO
GET REDACTED.
IN THE EFFORT TO ARGUE
AGAINST PROVIDING ANY OF THE
RELATED MATERIAL THAT WAS
SOURCED, SOME MIGHT SAY THAT
WE SHOULDN'T BE RELEASING
ANY OF IT, THE COUNTER
ARGUMENT THAT I WOULD
PROVIDE THOUGH TO THAT IS
THAT ANYTHING AT ALL THAT
ONE THING WHEN YOU READ THE
MAJORITY MEMO THAT WAS
RELEASED TODAY.
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN YOU
GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO READ
THE SCHIFF MEMO WHEN THAT
COMES OUT.
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY ARE SEEING
THE DOCUMENTS CREATED BY THE
OBAMA JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
OBAMA FBI AND YOU ARE SEEING
THE FISA ABUSE AND THE
MISCONDUCT AT THE HIGHEST
OWN INDEPENDENT JUDGMENT ON
THEIR OWN WITHOUT HAVING TO
RELY ON WHAT MIGHT BE
FILTERS OF ADAM SCHIFF
THROUGH A THIRD PARTY IN THE
ARE BEING EDUCATED ON
WAS GOING TO HAVE ALL THESE
SOURCES AND METHODS THAT
SHOULDN'T.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
POINT.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THOSE
DETAILS.
WHEN REALITY COMES OUT AND
THE MEMOS YOU CAN SEE FOR
YOURSELF.
YOU CAN FORM YOUR INDIVIDUAL
JUDGMENT.
PIVOTAL LINE IN THE MEMO
THAT SAYS ANDREW MCCABE
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
TESTIMONY TO THE INTEL
COMMITTEE SAID THE MEMO WAS
THE BASIS IN OR THE DOSSIER
WAS THE BASIS OF THE REQUEST
CAN WE GET A COPY OF THAT
PART, THE RELEVANT PART OF
HIS TESTIMONY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE SHOULD.
THEMSELVES ONCE AGAIN ADAM
SCHIFF AND THE HOUSE INTEL
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE JUST
LYING.
AS THEY SAID THEY WERE
COMPLAINING THAT DEVIN NUNES
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS JUST
GRAMMATICAL CHANGES AND
THOSE OTHER SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES THAT WERE MADE WERE
CHANGES REQUESTED BY THE
MINORITY ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE